hi guys I'm Eric Voss and we're starting
to get some information about Star Wars
Episode eight the last Jedi now it was
just pieces of footage shown only to a
small group of VIPs but I'm going to
break down what the footage was and what
big implications that can have on the
story of the last Jedi and boiler
whirring if you don't want to know
anything about the last Jedi because I'm
going to do some speculate okay so
recently Disney CEO Bob Iger was at the
Walt Disney Company annual meeting of
shareholders which open with a sizzle
reel showing a bunch of quick shots of
unreleased Disney properties coming out
to Sears including some from the last
Jedi he also showed what comes next
after the closing shot of the force
awakens with Rey returning Luke's
lightsaber to him on each toe but then
it turned out it was just a close-up of
Luke grabbing the lightsaber with both
hands and then a wide shot as we looked
upward toward the camera which yeah is
super trolly
never thought I'd feel bad for a bunch
of rich movie execs but the big stuff
everyone is talking about is what was
seen in that sizzle reel which opened
with a shot of Luke in some sort of cave
location asking who are you so if we
assume he's talking to Ray here the fact
that Luke doesn't recognize Rey is a
pretty big deal because remember the
force awakens left us with this big
mystery of how exactly ray and Luke
Skywalker are connected if at all many
thought that she might have been one of
his students back when he was still
trying to train new Jedi the same
students murdered by fellow student Ben
solo aka kylo Ren which we might have
seen in raised forth vision that we saw
in the force awakens and many believe
that before Luke went into reclusion
after this he helped one of those
younglings Rey escape but now either
some version of that is true and Luke
just doesn't remember her or it's not
true it also seems a little less likely
that Rey is Luke Skywalker's daughter
because you think that the force would
caused Luke to be able to sense his own
blood the way that he could feel his
family ties to his father and sister
now of course Luke asking who are you
doesn't necessarily shoot down either
these theories he may have just been an
exile so long that his memory has faded
or maybe his force abilities aren't what
they were also there was some confusion
out there that this line was spoken
during that exterior lightsaber hand-off
scene making who are you maybe the first
spoken line of episode 8 but actually
it's in a different location so that
might not be the case either way Luke
asking Rey who are you would be a super
interesting line to open the last Jedi
because really that's one of the big
mysteries we want this movie to answer
who is Ray and is she one of the last
Jedi and yeah I say one of because we
know from foreign translations that Jedi
is plural and quickly here's a rundown
of the other shots supposedly in the
sizzle reel there are shots of Rey
training and testing out her force
abilities like spinning around Luke's
lightsaber stretching out her hand over
the ground and levitating the dirt
there's also a wide shot of the island
with Rey practicing with the lightsaber
on the cliffside as Luke watches so I'm
guessing we're going to see a lot of
rage training in Episode eight kind of
like how a big portion of the Empire
Strikes Back was Luke training with Yoda
there's also a quick shot of the late
Carrie Fisher at general Leia Organa
with the hologram of the resistance
fleet behind her then there's Poe
Dameron yelling it's now or never to vd8
as the pilot says x-wing there are also
shots of other fighters flying through a
lineup of the resistance leet as Wella
is a shot of a banged-up x-wing flying
into a resistance hangar with its nose
popping up as it breaks quickly in the
air this could be Poe's x-wing maybe is
the return from battle in one piece
they're also about two shots of new
locations mountains oceans forests and
deserts and shots of Chewbacca roaring
and Captain phasma glad to see that her
role in the Star Wars saga isn't limited
to her getting tackled by Chewie and
stuffed down a trash compactor on
Starkiller base and finally and this is
a real there's a shot of thin dressed as
a first-order officer on the bridge of a
first-order ship standing beside Kelly
Marie trans new character she's rumored
to be playing a ax who's an information
broker who sells intelligence and helps
in escape at some point so it seems like
the last Jedi
could be using the same traditional Star
Wars move of the heroes and disguise of
bad guys we'll see okay that covers all
the rumors
shots from that sizzle reel and I know
that it sucks that we can't see any of
it but don't worry Star Wars Celebration
is in April and I'm assuming we'll get
at least the teaser for the last Jedi so
we'll get a real look at this movie soon
and let me know what you think in the
comments and make sure to like this
video and subscribe to new rockstars and
if you really like us you can contribute
to us on patreon big thanks to our
current patron you can hit me up on
Twitter at da box with any thoughts or
theories you have about Star Wars the
last Jedi or follow new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
our videos alright thanks for watching
bye